je vous le disais dans les titres à un
an des JO de Paris les valeurs de
l'olympisme ont déjà franchi les murs
des prisons ce jeudi à la maison d'arrêt
de Blois les détenus avaient la
possibilité de pratiquer différentes
activités sportives un moment de détente
pour eux qui passent de nombreuses
œuvres dans leur cellules un temps aussi
pour voir différemment le personnel
pénitentiaire les la Turquie avec
Clémence dosc
[Musique]
ope
les détenus de la maison d'arrêt de
Blois alternent entre rameurs course de
vitesse et quiz sportif derrière ces
animations une logistique rigoureuse et
la mobilisation de tous les personnels
objectifs lutter contre l'oisiveté en
cellule et inciter au dépassement de soi
ça nous fait beaucoup de bien pour la
prison car on peut sortir s'amuser
profiter des au détenus à l'air libre ça
motive vraiment aussi ça me permet de me
remettre en question etc de voir que de
permettant de canaliser d'apprendre
comment me canaliser etc pour ça nous
permet de nous sociabiliser avec avec
les intervenants extérieurs et nos
responsabiliser ça fait du bien au moral
surtout c'est important de sortir un
petit peu et d'avoir des activités avec
des gens et de se sentir un petit peu
libre entre guillemets une bouffée
d'oxygène pour mieux digérer la dureté
carcérale et dont les bénéfices sont
multiples outre la possibilité de se
dépenser les activités mobilisent
l'écoute et la communication à la fois
entre les détenus et les intervenants
l'objectif il est à la fois sportif à la
fois sociale à la fois culturelle on
suit les règles qui nous sont fixées
c'est la base du sport en fait il y a
des règles on suit les règles et si on
ne suit pas les règles
l'arbitre siffle faute voilà
camaraderie respect et discipline les
valeurs de l'olympisme sont transverses
au-delà d'une image de décontraction le
chef de l'établissement rappelle les
enjeux sociaux et éducatifs du projet le
sport est essentiel en détention au même
titre que le travail l'école les soins
non ils s'amuse pas ils sont ils luttent
aussi contre l'oisiveté ils sont
enfermés ils ont la possibilité de
s'inscrire aux activités de se mobiliser
au cours de leur détention donc nous
c'est ça aussi qui va nous intéresser
des bénéfices dans les détenus sont
conscients comme en témoignent leur
sérieux tous le savent un bon
comportement et gage d'autres activités